good morning job mommies they still in
the studio they're tracking banjo in the
other room didn't ever think to be banjo
dragon on my albums but I'm not here to
talk about music today John I'm here to
talk about how to apologize so I would
nerdfighteria these past seven years has
been don't forget to be awesome and that
is a good slogan not because it is easy
but because it is hard being awesome
requires constant vigilance and you will
slip up whether because of ignorance or
because of selfishness or because of
outright malice or because you're drunk
but you have a choice after you've done
something crappy you can transform into
one of two things either you can regain
your awesome through actual apology or
you can become the fart bag a fart bag
this is a technical definition is a
person who hurts someone and then blames
the person they hurt for their pain it's
like if I step on your toe and then you
were like Al and then I was like god
stop standing everywhere I understand
you didn't mean the step on the person's
toe but you still did and they're in
pain and you caused it so apologize so I
put together some do's and don'ts on how
to be awesome and not be a fart bag
don't blame people for how they feel if
you're telling someone that you've hurt
to not be so sensitive it that there's
such a delicate flower that they don't
understand how the world works they
don't understand your suffering what
you've been through you're being a part
bad you feel bad I am sick of this idea
that we're supposed to go through life
experiencing the absolute minimum
negative emotions if you did something
sucky you're supposed to feel bad about
it that's the definition of a conscience
that's supposed to go supposed to be
don't if you're apologizing think that
you're asking for forgiveness that's not
what you're doing you have done
something crappy to a person you should
not then like go forward and make
additional requests oh [ __ ] yes you can
hope that your apology results in
forgiveness you can hope for that but
you are not requesting that to figure
out what you did wrong figured out
understand it believe it internalize it
otherwise your apology is just gonna be
a little puh because you're not gonna
actually think you did anything wrong or
you're gonna end up blaming the person
who is hurt
fart bad to figure out why you did the
hurtful things maybe it was because
ignorance maybe because of insecurity
maybe because you were having a really
super bad day and you really needed a
snack spend that time in your own head
figuring out and then don't make excuses
but do provide context the other person
or the people understanding why you did
what you did is not going to excuse what
you did and it's not gonna fix what you
did but it might help them understand
why you did what you did and
understanding is a really powerful force
in human relationships don't just
express sympathy you can express
sympathy but not just that you also have
to accept the blame you are not sorry
that your friend is hurt you are sorry
that you hurt your friend tell the
people that you hurt that you can see
what you have done you know that you
cannot undo it but you will not do it
again and the future don't think that
you are losing or that you are
submitting the biggest cause of fart
beggary is the belief that all social
interactions are zero-sum games and now
I'm trying to win over you and then if I
get you to apologize then I have won
some kind of battle apologizing is not a
sign of weakness people say that all the
time it's a sign of strength it's a sign
that you and your ego are strong enough
to handle it when you make a mistake
it's been some interesting research on
this actually and it turns out that
people who apologize feel weaker but are
perceived as stronger people whereas
fart bags feel stronger but they are
perceived by the people around them as
weaker under which one of those I'd
rather don't forget to tell the people
that you hurt how you are going to
change and finally do change because
otherwise you are just a very eloquent
lying fart bag John I'll see you on
Tuesday hey guys so today I want to talk
about getting called out and how to
apologize what you're supposed to do
when you get called out and the way to
apologize so that people believe you and
know you're actually committed to change